all right let's talk about the Kanye
West video in which he says he likes
Hitler he likes Nazis now before I even
get into this I want to say right up
front there are people who are
not in agreement with the things Kanye
is saying but are dismissing this as
merely being a very public mental health
episode and that that's the only thing
the only commentary the only analysis
that needs to be looked at Ben Shapiro
right wing commentator is one of these
people where he says obviously I don't
agree with this stuff he's Jewish being
Ben Shapiro and he doesn't agree that
Hitler was good or whatever
but that this is nothing this isn't it
has nothing to do with politics has
nothing to do with Society or culture
it's just Kanye having
some kind of mental health episode
it is clear from everything we have seen
that there is a mental health component
to this but it doesn't matter
in terms of the effect that this can
have on people who already sometimes
dabble in these sorts of beliefs
anti-semitic beliefs and who need very
little to be pushed
to the next level where those beliefs
grow and grow and grow and they can go
as we saw in the World War II era from
just ideas that crazy people say come on
that's it give me a break into much
bigger and terrible things so let's not
do the thing where we go just a crazy
person doesn't matter there's an entire
movement and by the way
this Nick Fuentes guy who was on The
Alex Jones Show alongside Kanye a couple
of days ago
is are all the things he says also
simply a mentally ill you know a mental
illness episode
less clear so let's just go right into
it these clips are literally beyond
belief except they're not what I mean by
that is if I simply told you six years
ago hey here's a thing that Kanye is
going to say nobody would believe it
but then now of course it's exactly the
stuff that he is saying Kanye West Nick
Fuentes after their dinner with Trump
appearing on the Alex Jones Show you're
not Nazi you don't deserve to be called
that a demonized well
I I see I I see good things about Hitler
also I love everyone and Jewish people
are not going to tell me you can love
um
you know us and you can love what we're
doing to you with the contracts right
and you can love what we're you know
what we're pushing with the pornography
but this guy that
invented highways invented the very
microphone that I use as a musician you
can't say out loud that this person ever
did anything good and I'm done with that
I'm done with the classifications every
human being has something of value that
they brought to the table yep and Kanye
wants to fight for the value of talking
about the good things Hitler did now by
the way Kanye has no clue what he's
talking about he says Hitler invented
the microphone most microphones in use
today or thanks to James West who was a
black inventor not because of Hitler
inventing the microphone it's you know
it's completely outrageous uh here's
more of this stuff if you can believe it
I've been a lot of study I think Hitler
was a really bad guy and I repudiate
what Hitler did I understand that the
British intelligence set him up and used
him I like Hitler I don't like Hitler
and I know there you go and look at the
look at Nick Fuentes with this stupid
grin on his face
this is a big victory folks they've got
one of the most
recognizable well-known uh black musical
artists and celebrities generally saying
I like Hitler this is a major victory
for people like Nick Fuentes and the
white nationalist movement they are
absolutely loving this trying to be
shocking with that I'm not trying to be
shocking I like Hitler I do not I the
the Holocaust is not what happened let's
look at the facts of that and Hitler has
a lot of redeeming qualities
well CNN says why people are evil Nazis
so I mean I I disagree with both
statements but I guess I don't like the
word evil next to Nazis I think we need
to look at
um and the Nazis should not be aware
thugs That Shook people down to a lot of
really bad things but they did good
things too we're going to stop dissing
the Nazis all the time okay
I never had a supermodel yeah could tell
the Jewish media has made us feel like
the Nazis and Hitler have never offered
anything of value to the world okay well
why would the Zionist be killing Jews in
mass in Israel with the poison shot
because they'd work for Satan they don't
work for God exactly okay so this stuff
is completely Beyond The Pale I mean
it's it it's beyond any analysis you
can't analyze it for its substance and
there's a moment which is sort of
surreal where even Alex Jones tries to
get Kanye to walk back some of his
statements and Kanye just doubles down
even further I don't think Hitler was a
good guy I get the uh the Hugo Boss
uniforms amazing uh but I mean just
because you're in love with the design
you're a designer can we just kind of
say like you like the you like the
uniforms but that's about it oh we we no
there's a lot of things that I love
about Hitler
and look at Nick Fuentes grinning and
nodding along
a lot of things wow
wow folks this is
what how how can we say this is a
meaningless lone nut
when there's an entire movement behind
the guy there are people who are behind
these messages and they're increasingly
prominent Nick Fuentes met with Trump he
had dinner with Trump the other day and
so it's really important that we not
allow this as sometimes happens with
anti-Semitism I've said it before some
in the audience don't like when I point
this out
uh we shouldn't have a different
threshold for anti-Semitism than we do
for other isms or discriminatory
statements and claims and whatever the
case may be okay this is dangerous stuff
and
when we talk about it it's not about
saying Kanye is the next Hitler that's
not at all what the analysis is
but it's important to remember that
there were lots of people in pre-World
War II era Germany who would say a lot
of this rhetoric that's floating around
about Jews and all the different things
it's just rhetoric it's never going to
go anywhere there's no it has no teeth
there's no way it could ever go anywhere
and when people assume that that's how
more happens now you don't have to jump
to the Holocaust you can just go to well
more societal acceptance of
public shaming of Jews for example right
there's all these little steps in
between before we get the Holocaust you
don't have to go to that
um one last thing here the uh there was
just an interesting kind of moment where
uh Kanye says that Trump actually loved
Nick Fuentes at the dinner that they
went to this is the future president
you're talking to right now
is Nick your running mate
he's not old enough
yeah Nick how old are you I'm 24. it's
maybe in a few cycles and and Trump
loved Nick he looked at me he said where
did you find this kid yeah now that's
interesting because that's exactly the
type of language Trump would use where
did you find this kid straight out of
Central Casting huh no idea until what's
the guy that wrote the speech that you
didn't like Jason Miller the Jason
Miller lied afterwards after they found
out who you were and what did Jason say
in the press to start off because it it
started to be like a series of lie after
live to lie and fake it wasn't a tweet
it was a true social after truth social
after true social so give them the
rundown on that yeah so initially we
didn't publish anything about the dinner
it was rumored that yay went to dinner
with Trump then it was rumored that I
was at the dinner because I walked
through the airport in Miami then there
was a statement from Jason Miller who
spoke as a representative for Trump and
he said well Nick Fortress was not at
the dinner and it was only at that point
which was a lie it was only at that
point when we began to respond and yes
said he can't say that Nick was at the
dinner that was a lie but I mean I
actually like the species of Jason
Miller Road maybe yeah so Alex Jones
still desperately trying to kind of keep
some kind of Bridge to Trump there to
some degree this is extraordinarily
dangerous stuff and uh sure Kanye West
probably mentally ill seems pretty clear
but we're not going to write off this
entire movement which by the way has
been around for what thousands of years
and say no it's not meaningful it's not
important because Kanye is mentally ill
we're not going to do it and by the way
you've got to see the reactions of some
to this stuff that happened over the
last few days I love reading I read
every day no matter how I arrange my
schedule I never have enough time to
read all the books that I want which is
why blinkist has been such an important
part of my life for years now our
sponsor blinkist is the app that takes
thousands of non-fiction books boils
them down into an explainer that you can
read or listen to in just 15 minutes
which includes all the the most
important takeaways from the book with
blinkist I can absorb the essence of 15
different books in an afternoon so I can
quickly gather insights from all sorts
of perspectives make connections have
those kind of aha moments that don't
happen so easily which is why I feel
enriched when I use blinkist blinkist
also summarizes episodes of popular
podcasts into 15-minute explainers and
with the blinkist connect feature my
girlfriend and I can share one account
share books podcasts with each other
talk about them on the go and don't
forget blinkus makes the perfect holiday
gift my audience can try blinkist free
for seven days and get 25 percent off
after that go to blinkist.com Pacman the
link is down below